- Can we just like, take a minute?
(audience cheering and clapping)
- You look-
You always look so fabulous.
- Thank you. Thank you.
I'm trying not to expose
myself on daytime television.
- [Kelly] You're gonna
Sharon Stone everyone?
I like it. I like it.
(Yvie cackling)
Sometimes it happens.
(Monet laughing)
Wait, so could you all introduce
yourselves to everybody?
And then, oh, I see those contacts.
Okay. Yes!
I like it, I like it.
So tell everybody your drag names,
and how you got to your drag names.
- So my name is Monet X Change.
- [Kelly] Yep.
- And it's really simple.
I was eating some, some sticky wings
at the Dallas BBQ on Times Square.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love-
- And across the street
was a currency exchange.
I was like, that's so boring.
What about money?
Put an E, an accent on an E and a T,
Monet, Monet X Change.
- I love that-
(audience laughing and clapping)
(Kelly clapping)
- [Monet] Right?
Every good drag name should
start with chicken wings.
- [Kelly] Oh my God, love it.
Oh my gosh.
Your eyes are beautiful as well.
- Thank you.
- Yes. Okay.
So, say name and like how
you came up with your name.
- Howdy y'all, I'm Yvie Oddly. And-
I just like threw letters
in a bag, pulled them out.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- I was like, I'm just like-
fine. This looks good.
- Now people called me a weirdo.
So I ran with it.
I was like, maybe I can make
a brand out of being weird.
So it's actually like
a pun on even and odd,
but like I said, I can't spell.
(queens laughing)
- I like that, Yvie Oddly-
That's really cute.
I was called weird too.
Look at us now, whatever!
- [Monet] I know!
- Yeah.
- And now we're so boring.
(queens laughing)
No, all those people
peaked in high school.
We're so cool.
Okay. So name and then how
you came up with your name?
- Hi, I'm Shea.
Miss Coulee if you nasty.
(Kelly laughing)
I came up with my name
because my middle name is Shea
and it's Swahili, it means beautiful boy.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love that.
- And I came up with Coulee,
because there's this little
African riddle, that's like,
♪ Shea Shea Coulee ♪
♪ Shea Konfisa, Konfisa Lala, ♪
♪ Ala Kyelala ♪
So-
- [Kelly] Ala Kyelala-
- So I like to turn up to that song.
So I said, Shea Coulee.
- I love that.
(audience clapping)
I didn't know that that was Swahili
or it meant beautiful boy.
That's- I love that.
- [Shea] Thank you.
- It was destiny.
I like that.
Okay. Okay.
Raja, how about you?
Look at, look at what's hap-
(Raja laughing)
I love what's happening, like, okay.
So how did you come up with your name?
- I'm Raja, and I got my name, actually,
because I'm Indonesian, and in Indonesian,
Raja actually means king.
- [Kelly] Ooh!
- And also at the time,
when I was first starting to do drag,
"Aladdin," the film had just come out
and there's a tiger named Raja.
And I was also born in
the year of the tiger.
So it all kind of went together.
- Oh, that was just kind of meant to be.
(audience clapping)
I love that.
That reminds me of John Legend,
his last name and legend.
Right? He just was like, I'm a legend.
I'm gonna call myself a legend.
- [Yvie] Really?
- I know!
- Oh!
- [Kelly] It's Stevens!
- [Monet] Oh, wow!
- [Kelly] I was like,
but I love that.
He was like, naw. Legend.
(queens laughing)
Yeah. And I love that you
were like, king. This bit.
I like it.
I, I should have picked a cooler name.
(queens laughing)
So, so how did you, how
did you all get into drag?
Raja, I'll start with you.
- I'm probably here on this panel,
I've been doing it the longest.
And I think it, it was, you
know, it's been 30 years
since I started doing
drag for the first time.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Raja] And at that time
it was, it was irreverent.
It was rebellion.
And it was just kind of, you know,
it was just something to do-
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- just to kind of make my parents little-
- [Kelly] It's very creative.
(Raja laughing)
I mean, Lord, it's so cool.
But Shea, how about you?
- It was like, kind of an accident.
I went to school for theater
and I was supposed to
be dancing in the chorus
for this all black burlesque review
called "Jeezy's Juke Joint,"
and my good friend, Jeez Louise,
she sent out the email
to everybody in the cast
and she was just like
in the email, she goes,
"If you have a solo act,
please reply with the
details for your act."
And so naturally, what I read was,
" You, Shea Coulee, have a solo act!"
(queens laughing)
So I came up with a whole act.
I did this number to a
Beyonce song, "Sugar Mama,"
this like cute little burlesque number,
and got a standing ovation.
And I never had that response ever.
And I was like, I think that
there's something to this.
Maybe I should do drag.
- Yeah! Well, and it feels
good when you're on stage
and you're doing something you love.
And then somebody that, you know, that-
- Absolutely.
- [Kelly] And the vibe is reciprocated.
That's really cool.
I, I love that you've
filtered that as like,
they want me to do a solo.
(queens cackling raucously)
- Right?
- [Kelly] I'm gonna, that's
how I'll filter critiques.
Like any, anytime a critic
like, says something,
I'm just like, so you loved it.
(queens laughing)
Great. Great. Love that.
Yeah. I feel good.
OK. So you're, I've filtered that (bleep).
So your, your parents found out
you did drag by watching "Drag Race?"
- Yes. You know?
So again, so being in the arts,
I was always coming home with
like some crazy thing, right.
And then right when I started doing drag,
I would come home with
like a wig like this.
My mom would be like, "What is that?"
I'm like, it's this crazy performance of
"The Magic Flute," girl.
You're not gonna believe it.
We're wearing wigs!
(queens and Kelly laughing)
I was coming in with
like, eight inch pumps.
Like "what's with the shoes?"
Girl, "The Marriage of
Figaro," is getting crazy, Mom.
(Kelly and queens laughing uproariously)
I was just build it like that.
So, until I got the show,
I got cast on the show, and I started,
and the show was, it was like two weeks
before the show aired.
I was like, all right, here it is.
And I told her about it and she was like,
"Girl?!? Woooooord!."
- [Kelly] She was-
- Yeah, she was into it!
And now my family has
like group chats about it.
- [Kelly] Oh my God!
- [Monet] And they're like,
oh my God, that Maddie Morphosis,
I'm like, y'all know more
about the show than me!
Than I do.
(Yvie cackling)
- Like, they love it.
- [Kelly] I love that!
- They love, they love it. Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
That doesn't happen for everybody.
Everybody's not supported in like, their-
especially, people in the arts.
- [Monet] Yeah.
- Like, they're like, no, I
need you to get a real job.
Like, that's what they always tell us.
- Yeah. Especially Caribbean parents,
Caribbean parents are all about-
"You gonna be a doctor or lawyer.
There's no ifs, ands or buts."
And I'm like, I'm kind of like a lawyer-
(queens and Kelly laughing)
Ish.
- I play one on TV?
So Yvie, what was it like when
you went back home to Denver?
So, after you won?
- No, it was just,
it was the most validating
experience I'd ever felt.
'Cos I felt like growing
up that, that Denver
wasn't a place for me
to be anything bigger
than a doctor or a lawyer
which I should have been.
(Kelly and queens laughing)
But no, no.
I just felt like I, I had
so much I wanted to do
and that I was never going
to be able to break out
and be bigger than that.
And so coming home and
being celebrated for like,
something that I, I pushed
so long and so hard for.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Yvie] And to see,
like all these people who helped build me,
it was, it was everything.
- [Kelly] And you know,
what's cool too is like,
you said maybe you felt like
you didn't fit in there,
but what's cool is that
there's other people there
right now that might feel that way too.
And like, you're a good example of, like,
you can,
anybody anywhere can
achieve anything they want.
We all have big dreams and
that where you're from.
- That's- yeah.
That's like the biggest
thing I honestly learned,
not even just from going
back home but every-
everywhere I've gone, I've-
I've met the other people.
The people who feel like
they, they have no place.
And so I tell them they can't sit with me.
(Kelly and queens laughing)
- I tell them there's no room in the inn.
(audience clapping)
Yeah.